[Music]
who won't be the next man handing out
the Rose is well one thing's for sure
bachelor nation knows who they want it
to be
say this doesn't work out would you be
the bachelor right now I mean really
honest
Rachel's definitely focus a source tells
ET producers are still interested in
Peter as the next Bachelor
this despite yesterday's tweet from show
creator Mike Fleiss which scenes a throw
shade Peters way a red quote do we
really want a bachelor who isn't ready
to settle down with a woman he loves hmm
not what The Bachelor is all about what
if I'm not ready to say will you air me
yeah that moment still isn't sitting
well with Bachelorette Rachel either
she told us she doesn't want Peter to be
the bachelor I've said Alex should be
the next Bachelor I've always said that
we're told an announcement isn't
expected to happen anytime soon and that
viewers shouldn't read too much into
fleiss's tweet our source says he might
be trying to throw fans off thank you so
much hey I'm super excited meantime
another name in the mix Dean unblurred
he'll get a lot of screen time on
Monday's bachelor in paradise when he
starts romancing a new woman here's to
getting super dirty then on Tuesday
we'll see Demario sit down with Chris
Harrison about this season scandal
Corinne speaks herpes the week after how
would you describe how that went in a
few words it's emotional I was a wreck
yeah Chris knows how to Chris knows how
to poke the bear he's great at what he
does he's and I eat him and I we've had
our differences but that was amazing
halfway through he's like you're killing
this because it just was raw uncut
emotions
[Music]
you